about our democracy for a minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah the smell of
freedom of speech
this is the tony michaels podcast and
this
is tony michaels hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
good afternoon everybody happy saint
patrick's day for what that's worth
[Music]
we are here today to talk about a few
things
as we always do on wednesdays at three
o'clock central four o'clock eastern
we have some good subjects to talk about
today today is not just st
patrick's day but apparently today is
the day that all the
bitin stemi checks got put into the bank
uh everyone's a buzz about the the
stimulus payments they got dumped into
their bank accounts today so
there is that to talk about uh we're
also going to talk about uh mitch
mcconnell's little
turtle tortoise tantrum on the floor
about the filibuster he's terrified of
the filibuster of course there is
certain certainly reasons why they are
terrified of this filibuster
why why that scares the absolute bejesus
out of the republicans we've got that um
we also have uh the covet spring
breakers that i want to
address give them a little bit of um
of my attitude but we had yesterday we
had a
shooting in atlanta uh
some young white dude with a gun went
and killed
eight people six of them are asian women
at
massage parlors and spas apparently
there were three different locations
that this person drove through and
murdered these people
[Music]
uh i guess the the place to start here
because we're going to end up talking
about some of the statements that law
enforcement made
at the press conference
this morning but the place to start
is
with these [ __ ]
racist republicans
continuing and happened since this covet
stuff started
to blame covid
on asian people calling it the china
virus the wuhan flu
you know on and on and on and on the
racial tropes and
epithets continued and continued and
continued and continued
from donald trump the president united
states when it was going on
on down to the secretary of state mike
pompeo
and every other piece of [ __ ] garbage
that lives inside the republican party
at this point
there's been upticks in violence against
asian americans
for months and months and months people
have been
screaming hey stop calling it that [ __ ]
you're putting these people's lives in
danger
oh well that's where it comes from
that's where it comes from
that ain't where it comes from
continuing continuing and that's the
purpose
they want to scare their white voters
into thinking that
black brown people
and people who don't look white are the
cause of all their problems
and that's why we must have white
grievance
that's their [ __ ] purpose that's the
whole intention behind it
and enough is enough of this [ __ ] we
need to cut this [ __ ]
out
and then they're trying to say that
somehow that this this kid
he was horny that's why he did it he's
horny
he's he's got a sex addiction
when he any any [ __ ] person that's
young enough to remember yeah you got a
sex edition
sex edition when you're young most of
the time
being horny doesn't make you violent
want to murder people
may make you want to jack off or get get
your pleasure off or get your rocks off
but it does not make you want to [ __ ]
murder people
me a [ __ ] break and for law
enforcement for law enforcement to act
like that's going to be the problem here
is all he was horny he had a boner
he had a boner and a gun and if we gotta
get worried about
white dudes in this country who have
guns and boners we're in [ __ ] trouble
big trouble
that ain't what this is i'm sure what
we're gonna learn and i don't usually
surmise on stuff you guys know that
i'm sure what we're gonna learn is law
enforcement didn't want these massage
parlors in the first place
because they thought rubbing tugs were
going on there
and they think they're the enemy
not the guy shooting at him who cares if
rubbing tugs are illegal
it doesn't warn a death sentence you
dumb [ __ ]
and again you don't go murder people
because you got a woody
that's that's not a thing
we know why we know why we don't have to
[ __ ] guess
we know why
white mentally unstable scared
fearful fear-mongered
delusional white dudes with guns
yeah [ __ ] break horny
he had a sex addiction he was horny so
he wasn't shot no he didn't
and then and then at the press
conference for the [ __ ] to say
oh yeah well he was just having a bad
day he was just having one of those days
just one of those days you know where
you want to go murder asian people
give me a [ __ ] break shut your
[ __ ] mouth enough is enough of this
garbage
and someone needs to check the [ __ ]
skull of that law enforcement officer
give him a head examination he's having
a bad day
he had a bad day [ __ ] you
had a bad day
now we don't know everything about this
incident but it's starting to come into
focus here
that law enforcement wants to try to
make
the massage parlors the enemy
who cares if rubbing tugs were going on
there that doesn't mean people should
get
murdered what are you crazy blaming it
on
boners of course they are
we need we need to get some [ __ ] right
in this country [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm sure there'll be more to come
and i'm sure next week as we learn more
i will talk more about this and i'm sure
i'm almost positive there's going to be
some walking tick tock rants about this
as well
so be on the lookout for those
but right now it's very clear that
they're trying to press the blame
somewhere where it does not belong
you don't need to get your rocks off
and go shoot up a massage parlor you
watch pornhub
and rub one out everyone knows that
likes like people don't have access to
to the ability
to pleasure yourself so you gotta go
kill someone get the [ __ ] out of here
the [ __ ] out of here
so as we learn more i'll talk more
on that subject but we need to make it
clear in this country
we are going to stop this [ __ ]
violence against asian americans
because these conservatives just can't
stop blaming
their woes their white grievance on
someone who doesn't look like them
that's enough of this [ __ ] already
put this [ __ ] to bed
it's hard to go from a subject like that
to the other subjects
but i'm gonna try to manage here
today's st patrick's day
it is the 17th of march had to double
check
everyone's getting their their biting
cha-ching bling
stemi checks today
uh apparently a lot of them dumped into
accounts today was the day that they
were going to be
put into people's bank accounts
automatic bank accounts
so everyone's excited to have their
stimulus checks finally of course
most people stimulus checks i'm sure are
[ __ ] gone
uh we were i was talking about this
earlier that uh yeah it's nice to get a
stimulus
and we should get a stimulus and and a
lot of people in this country are going
to get the child
the the child stimulus as well the child
check the child stimulus
but there's other things there's other
things that could be done
for the last year where we got [ __ ]
hammered
by this virus and hammered by the
economy because a lot of
a lot of politicians republicans in
particular
didn't want to do what the [ __ ] they
were supposed to do and require people
to wear masks and
require social distancing and do the
things that we needed to do to get the
virus under control
so that we could get the economy back
they just wanted to oh [ __ ] it ah [ __ ]
em
just try yeah check just go out to the
grocery store go cough on people have
your barbecues
heavier events [ __ ] up that virus don't
give a [ __ ]
spreading it around destroying
destroying the possibility for us to
have a decent [ __ ] economy
really honestly what they did other
countries did this
australia new zealand a lot of countries
in asia japan
korea china and you know what the thing
the thing the biggest difference that
we're seeing between
us europeans and those countries is they
have a mass
culture meaning when people get sick
or when you are sick yourself when you
yourself are sick when you go out in
public you
do the common courtesy thing and put on
a [ __ ] mask so you don't get everyone
else sick
they do that over there they're willing
to have
[ __ ] manners
not here by god not here
my body my choice when it comes to a
face mask
when it comes to anything else it is not
your body it is not your choice
you can't if you're a woman you can't
have a [ __ ] abortion
if if you're lgbtq you cannot you cannot
have sex with who you want to have sex
with
hell if you're if you're [ __ ] if if
you're [ __ ] cardi b
you can't even dance the way you want to
dance on tv
somehow it's a front to candace owens
cause
cardi b's dancing a certain way get the
[ __ ] out of here
your body your choice only when it comes
to mask only when it comes to masks
that [ __ ] outta here [ __ ] [ __ ]
but we got our stimulus checks some
people are happy but we it should go a
little further
and i did a video on the stimulus checks
so i want to play that and then we'll
talk a little more about these stimmies
this biden cha-ching bling
on the other side are you stimulated yet
let's talk joe biden signs the 1.9
trillion dollar coveted relief package
and republicans are pissed be kind of
hard to figure out why
because on one hand they don't want the
coronavirus package but on the other
hand they want to take credit for that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] eating morons if you voted no on
this bill you do not get to take credit
for the restaurant and business part
you [ __ ] you're starting to find out
that americans needed relief and like
the coronavirus package
and are gonna give joe biden credit your
daddy
even donald trump himself wants some of
that biden love
by grifting his supporters to send him
their biden
check and you trump loving chewing on
manga [ __ ] send that stimulus check to
your orange
deity that shriveled up cheeto and
bugger sugar junior blow your stimulus
check
on angel dust and hookers oh yeah and
when that biting cha-ching does hit your
account
thank the democrat blood-sucking cabal
for that because not one [ __ ]
republican voted for it
[ __ ] so there you go
laid it out in less than 60 seconds
so the republicans are absolutely pissed
about
the coronavirus relief package a lot of
different reasons the one reason why
is because they know the american people
are going to love this thing
and the longer it goes on here
the more they're going to like this
thing and what i mean by that is
already people are receiving stimulus
checks uh but
we're eventually it's it's going to
basically
uh ramp up the vaccination process
make sure to fund the infrastructure fun
getting those vaccinations into people's
arms which
while i'm on that topic please please
please
go get vaccinated if you can if you can
find a place to get vaccinated go do
that
whether it's the one you want or not if
you can find the one you want
go do that if you can't find the one
that you can get
uh the faster we get people vaccinated
the better off we are because we're
going to talk about the spring breakers
here in a little bit
and i have a an opinion about what is
going to happen if we don't get as many
people vaccinated in the next 30 days
that we possibly can so go get
vaccinated
do your part do your part go get
vaccinated
i don't want to get into the weeds here
on which one is better than the other
and which one this which one that and
what the vaccine does
[ __ ] it it's not worth it just go get it
let's not argue about this anymore go
get your vaccine
go get vaccinated now [ __ ]
that's it go get vaccinated now [ __ ]
do it so and the reason why is because
we want our economy
back and that's what this stimulus
package this
coronavirus relief package is designed
to do
it's not only designed to make sure that
enough people have enough money in their
pockets to make up for the last
12 goddamn months of the economy being
not only [ __ ] but stalled some people
made out like bandits but most people
did not
it extends the unemployment benefit
which means anyone who still cannot
still cannot go back to work because of
the coronavirus that is still there
that that's going to be a huge help the
kid that the child
credit that every the payments or the or
the tax credit
it's very unclear exactly how that's
going to work but i think that's why
it's not going to
be several months until that rolls out
but
we'll get that situated everyone's going
to love that part of it
because that's going to help make up for
what has happened over the last
12 months and into 18 months especially
if these
these people who are not paying
attention to the news and saying hey
the coronavirus isn't over yet you got
two or three months before we're really
at a hurt immunity situation
so you need to be [ __ ] patient we'll
talk about the spring breakers and those
other [ __ ] here in a minute
but the stimulus package the other thing
that's going to do is is make sure these
shots get in arms quicker than sooner
rather than later
and that is really really really really
really going to get us to a point to
where we need
to be faster than we would have been and
so we got donald trump on fox news which
jesus christ he's back to calling into
fox news
back where he was before 2016 he's
relegated to the old
call in the fox news and rambling on and
on and on
while he's on the [ __ ] or whatever
the [ __ ] he's doing
uh into his into his phone about this or
that
and this fight [ __ ] finally
admits that people should go get the
vaccine as if it even matters
if anyone who would make the decision to
go get the vaccine is even still
[ __ ] listening to fox news at that
point
then then he tries to try to take credit
for the for the vaccine and that's the
only reason why he told people to go get
it
is because he wanted to take credit for
it because everyone was saying i'll get
and credit biden's which biden should
get the credit for
actually getting the country in a
position where we can get the vaccine
at a timely rate the trump
administration had
virtually no [ __ ] plan it was just
yeah let the states have it they'll
figure it out
[ __ ] them they'll figure it out well
there was gonna be no federal push for
this vaccine
and it would happen sooner rather than
later and who gives a [ __ ]
[ __ ] it joe biden did not take that
approach joe biden put on his [ __ ]
shoes in the morning
he got out of bed put his [ __ ] shoes
on
walked down to the oval office and did
his [ __ ] job
hmm who would have thought waking up in
the morning and doing your goddamn job
would help
help get [ __ ] done who would have known
that was gonna [ __ ] happen
yeah when you do your job it gets done
now granted this is not gonna be perfect
nothing is perfect i mean this is a huge
endeavor i mean we're trying to
vaccinate
you know almost 300 million people of it
over 300 million people eventually once
they get the
the part for the underage people uh
figured out
and they can start uh vaccinating people
that are
you know school-aged children
it sounds like we're going to have
teenagers being able to be vaccinated
high schoolers being able to vaccinate
by the fall
and then next year sometimes school-aged
children be vaccinated
so once they get that figured out so
this is not gonna be perfect
it never was gonna be perfect it wasn't
designed to be perfect
but there is [ __ ] you can do
and he is doing and the best part is is
congress just passes
coronavirus relief package which gives
them the funds to go
do it that's a big thing so
uh as far as the the stimulus relief and
everything else
the other thing that that has happened
over the last
over the weekend really and really it
was almost right away
as soon as joe biden signed this thing
in the in the law and he was supposed to
sign it last friday but they moved it up
to try to get these checks out as soon
as possible
so they moved it up a day which
surprised everybody
but he was supposed to sign it on friday
but i mean before the [ __ ]
ink dries on that [ __ ] bill
republicans are out there going oh yeah
this part of the bill is [ __ ] awesome
i can't wait for my businesses in my
district to get this money and for
everyone to get their money and blah
blah blah
it's so great you voted against it
not one of you [ __ ] voted for
it not one goddamn [ __ ] republican
not
one we couldn't even get one
[ __ ] to vote for this thing
and be on the side of the american
people and the reason
why they couldn't do that the reason why
they couldn't get republicans to vote
for this [ __ ] thing is because it
helped
americans it gave money
to everyone in america
average people that's why they didn't
like this [ __ ]
they're big corporate donors and the one
percent
and all the rich [ __ ] donors on
the republican side didn't like it
because they didn't get enough
they loved the [ __ ] 1.9 trillion
dollars they passed
in a tax cut
and it [ __ ] piled money in rich
people's pockets
two years ago three years ago oh they
love that two trillion dollars
this two trillion dollars it just went
into the wrong hands it didn't go to the
job
creators give me a [ __ ] break
but they're happy they're happy that the
businesses and people are gonna get
money
they're happy to take credit for it they
just don't want to have to vote for it
because you know socialism or whatever
and what's what's what's really
crazy about this is [ __ ] three months
ago
three [ __ ] months ago
the house and the senate passed a
stimulus bill to give stimulus checks
and it was six hundred dollars and
instead of donald trump signing it at
the time the [ __ ] comes out in
front of microphone says this isn't
enough it needs to be 2000
and stalls and stalls and stalls and
stalls
and [ __ ] some people out of their
unemployment for a couple weeks because
of how he stalled it
signs it anyways which everyone knew he
was gonna do how i got a video on how he
was gonna sign it he didn't have a
choice
i got a video on it i don't have it
ready but i got a video on it i'll show
it to you later i guess
but he was to sign it and republicans
were like yeah
yeah we need 2 000. i mean you remember
that right josh hawley josh holly was
saying yeah we need 2
000. what the president said what he
said you [ __ ] democrats only got 600
we need 2
000. and bernie sanders and aoc chuck
schumer nancy pelosi like oh
well we got a bill that's 2 000 hell
yeah let's do that
we'll do that [ __ ] we got a bill ready
to go it won't take but two days past
that [ __ ]
nope nope they're only for
socialism when they gotta be for
socialism and it helps him out
makes him look good give me a [ __ ]
break
so i'm glad everyone got their stimulus
checks i'm glad that this stimulus
package got into play
i think we're gonna need some more uh
relief for americans i actually think
that the democrats
um once we get rid of the filibuster
which i'm gonna talk about here in a
moment or reform the filibuster we'll
talk about the two different ways
i think what we need to do is we need to
give americans more relief that's right
more relief
we need to make up for what people had
to [ __ ] skate by on with their
student loans
we need to make up for what people had
to skate by on with their mortgages and
their rent
and we also we also need to skate by
with health cost
we need more stimulus in those areas
to make up for that these cash payments
are not going to be enough to make up
for all that [ __ ] in the last year
now we can structure it a little
different i'm not saying just dump the
money in people's accounts
i'm not even a politician so i don't do
policy i just sit here and talk into a
microphone
but i think americans are ready for that
and i think we can tie in
the 15 an hour minimum wage to a bill
like that don't you
since we lost it in the last one because
we didn't work out
the whole filibuster thing for the last
coveted relief but it looks like we're
gonna work out the filibuster
republicans are getting scared they're
getting terrified of this filibuster
and there's only really one reason why
they're not scared they're not scared to
get rid of a filibuster when
when they want to jam through judges oh
they love that
[ __ ] they love getting rid of the
filibuster when it comes to them jamming
through judges and do whatever the [ __ ]
they want yeah [ __ ] yeah get rid of that
filibuster we want to do what we want
but when it's when at risk when it risks
passing the john lewis voting rights act
that's when they get terrified they
don't give a [ __ ] about 15
an hour minimum wage they don't give a
[ __ ] about that
that's all optics they don't give
they don't give two real [ __ ] about
this equality act either
that's all [ __ ] optics that's all so
marjorie taylor green can hang a bigoted
sign outside her office
that's it they just want to look like
bigots
they don't give a [ __ ] about that stuff
what they do care about what they do
give a holy [ __ ] about
they give a [ __ ] if they can suppress
the vote
because how do you think they stay in
power
huh you suppress the vote you stay in
power
you janu gerrymander you stay in power
the minority can rule because that's
what we have in this country
minority rule that's why everyone's so
[ __ ] frustrated with this
[ __ ] that's why no one can understand
why fifteen dollars an hour wasn't a
give me
in this last [ __ ] bill why
why couldn't you do that [ __ ] most
places in this country
pay more than 725 most states pay more
than 725 an hour anyways
they already have more than that minimum
wage so what's the [ __ ] arguing about
a lot of piece of places have over 15
hour minimum wage
not most but a lot so what's the
argument over no one can figure that out
well the arguing
[Laughter]
the argument has nothing to do with the
fifteen dollars now it's all optics
their party is not about ideas it hasn't
been for a long time because their ideas
[ __ ] suck
and they know that we know that they
know
that their ideas [ __ ] suck because
they [ __ ] suck
they're horrible their ideas are [ __ ]
absolute [ __ ] and most the american
people are not on their side when it
comes to these ideas
not a [ __ ] one of them
most americans want the opposite of what
they want
the exact opposite sometimes in most
cases
most cases like this coronavirus bill
jesus the majority of americans is 70 80
percent of america is like yeah past
this coronavirus
bill you think one or two republicans
would have been like man 70 80 percent
of people are on the border this
i probably need a vote for this
[ __ ] to look like i'm not a
piece of [ __ ]
nope not a goddamn one of them because
they're all pieces of [ __ ]
every [ __ ] last one of them
and that's why they're terrified of
getting rid of the filibuster mitch
mcconnell goes on the floor
i didn't watch him his speech on the
floor because that [ __ ] he puts me to
sleep
i read i read the parts that i need to
read and know what he was saying
and and the reason why mitch mcconnell's
on the floor saying what he's
making political threats whenever you
see mitch mcconnell making political
threats
he knows he's [ __ ] he knows he's
[ __ ]
you remember back when obama was
president he said our
number one goal is to get rid
of barack obama and make him a one-term
president remember that and that was
their goal and they were going to play
scorched earth politics
to make him a one-term president this
sounds familiar
does this sound familiar starting to
sound familiar
and the reason why is because he knew
barack obama was going to kick their ass
again
and he did
ran all up and down romney's ass
and they lost again to obama
but it's all bluster because everyone
want to makes mitch mcconnell some sort
of [ __ ] political genius
he's not a political genius the [ __ ]
just
holds enough power that he could smash
up whatever he wants to smash up
and he can get all these fascists to
back him to do it
because they're fascist that's not
that's not brilliance i mean
jesus broken clocks right twice a day
for [ __ ] sake
it's not brilliant to run into a room
full of
china and with a sledgehammer and smash
every plate and go oh i'm really good at
smashing
smashing china ain't i yeah of course
you are
swinging the hammer around like that
yeah you're gonna [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
every once in a while
this is not political genius
and they know they know if they lose the
filibuster and this john lewis voting
rights act
gets into play and and what the
john lewis voting rights act means is
that not only
not only are they going to risk the
filibuster over the next two years until
the midterm
and and possibly have a bunch of
legislation passed
not only that but they could possibly
lose their way
to gain back power in the midterms
because there's a hell of a lot of
senate races that are going to happen in
the midterms
and their plan is to suppress the vote
because guys
their ideas suck so what they gotta do
see what you gotta do when your ideas
suck is you just gotta get less people
to vote
and when i mean less people i mean less
people that would vote for you
and i when i mean when you're a racist
and you're placating to white grievance
what i mean is is just get just white
people to vote that's what i mean
that's what i'm talking about let's
let's just make it to where white people
can vote
real white people that's what we want
and not them young white people hell
they're woke
they won't vote for us so let's keep
them from voting too
that's the [ __ ] plan come on
their plan is to keep people who were
going to vote for
who will vote against them vote against
them and they're terrified because
there's 81 million people out there
that will [ __ ] vote against them
81 million people voted against trumpism
i do not believe
there is no way that 81 million people i
agree with trumpers on this they keep
saying oh 81 million people didn't vote
for biden hell no they didn't vote for
biden
81 million people did not vote for biden
they voted against trump
i mean i'm sure there's a lot of people
in there that like biden and love biting
and frankly
as we go along here biden's not is
turning out not to be
a bad executive he's not
and the one reason why is because joe
biden isn't doing doing the presidenting
thing
to re-run as president he's not [ __ ]
trying to figure out well
we could do this but god that would be
bad for my re-election
you guys get that sense
the biden administration is not setting
policy and doing things
so that they can get reelected or run a
re-election campaign
you guys that sense they are not
doing things
so that they can run a re-election
campaign they're just doing them because
it's the [ __ ] that's got to be done
and it's the [ __ ] they said they would
[ __ ] do huh
who would thought that that would be
popular which joe biden's got a huge
favorable rating
and i believe as long as joe biden keeps
keeps
presidenting to where he's not
concerned about the midterm election or
the next presidential election if he
continues to not give a two [ __ ] about
that
and just does gets his [ __ ] shoes on
and does his job every day and doesn't
give a [ __ ] about the next election or
election after that as long as he
continues to do that he's going to
have a very [ __ ] high favorable
rating in this country
he's going to have a very high and and
if he can get this filibuster either
abolish which i think that's what needs
to happen we need to get rid of the
filibuster all together but it doesn't
look like that's going to happen because
we have a guy named joe manchin
a democrat from west virginia that is
not willing to vote to abolish it
but what he is willing to do and i think
there was a little bit of trading going
on here
for the cro coronavirus relief package
where they dropped
they dropped from 400 to 300 on the
unemployment uh they changed around some
of the numbers for the people who are
getting the stimulus checks
and they they uh they also dropped the
15
hour minimum wage out of there and let
eight democrats vote against it
now the reason why joe manchin
is now he's saying let's reform
let's reform the the the filibuster
which joe biden did an interview
which was george stephanopoulos says the
same thing they're pretty much on the
same page it seems like
joe manchin and joe biden the two joes
the two uncle joe's have a deal here
and the deal is there's gonna be a
standing filibuster
and you gotta have 41 members on the
floor to do this [ __ ]
and that is the way the filibuster was
in the first place it wasn't this
[ __ ] where you just file and you
stamp
and you kill a bill that's all [ __ ]
a filibuster should not be able to to
kill a bill
the filibuster should be
should be to stall a bill
or to a negotiating point on a bill
maybe there's a little discrepancy maybe
there's a little
back and forth that that that caucuses
or part of caucuses are trying to
work out and they want to work that out
with a filibuster
fine but it's not designed to stymie and
kill legislation
that's not what it's designed for well
technically
the historical design of it was
to make sure that the south still had a
voice
that's what it was they got slavery
taken away from them they felt like they
were politically handicapped and the
only way to solve that was a filibuster
that was it there you go
of course everything in this country has
its roots in racism
it's what it is you like it or not
that's what it is but 50 years ago 40
years ago they had standing filibusters
if you ever seen mr smith goes to
washington
you know what a standing filibuster is
that's not how they do it now it's not
how it works
but that's how it should work and that's
what it looks like it's going to go back
to
which i said this last week if these
republicans have to actually do [ __ ]
work
and stand there and and talk for hours
and have 41 of them in the [ __ ]
chamber
while they're doing a filibuster they
are not gonna do that [ __ ]
they will not work that hard to [ __ ]
make it look like
they're doing something they what they
will do is they will go on fox news and
scream
socialism socialism cancel culture
socialism that's why they're gearing up
to do this that's what the whole mr
potato head [ __ ] is
the doctor sue [ __ ] it's all
[ __ ] distraction to try to to try to
to try to fear monger what base they
have left here because they're le
they're leaving in droves
leaving in droves because these people
that's all they got is potato head
potato head dr seuss socialism and nazis
that's what we're for by god nazis
and where it's turning out that a lot of
these [ __ ] insurrectionists
not only are uh are fascists but they're
straight-up nazis they
they even were going to work uh making
themselves look like hitler
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
so so we're gonna get which sounds like
we're gonna get some reform on this
filibuster i
i really think we don't need the
filibuster we don't need this [ __ ]
there's plenty other procedure that's
in the senate procedure for the floor
for the senate to actually
uh negotiate a bill we don't need the
filibuster anymore
uh information travels way too fast
these days to even need a filibuster
i mean that's really what the filibuster
was designed to do is to
is to stall and to take time
for people for the word to get out to
your constituents to see how the
constituency feel well you know why
we know we know what americans think in
a moment's notice give me a break
[ __ ] something happens twitter blows up
we know
we know this ain't no [ __ ] this ain't
no [ __ ] secret we know what the hell
that
the pulse of america is and we know that
the pulse of america was on the side
of joe biden and get rid of trump we
know we know that the american people
were
for the relief package they were for the
stimulus checks
we know the majority of americans are
for the vaccine we know all this stuff
we know it and we don't need we don't
need someone to stall
legislation on the floor to make sure
that constituents know what's going on
in washington
it doesn't take that much of rocket
science it's fast it's quick we know we
don't need the filibuster
you don't need to stall anymore there's
no reason to stall there's plenty other
procedure to negotiate
plenty of other procedures to negotiate
and the republicans weren't for the
filibuster when they needed to ram
through all their conservative judges
because they thought well our last
chance here is to ram through
conservative judges
because our ideas suck enough that we
won't get [ __ ] elected if they do
pass a voting rights bill
so we're really [ __ ] so our last
measure is to install
a conservative court that way they can
stymie any legislation or any lawsuits
against us
and that's our last last ditch effort
here to make sure this country stays
conservative
fascist conservative fascist
that's all conservatism has been the
last 40 years is a thin
veil of [ __ ] fascism and enough is
enough of this [ __ ] already so we need
to end the filibuster and i did a video
about it
i know that's a long ways to go to get
to my video
but i did a video about it so i'm gonna
play it and uh
it's it's about uh it's about old mitch
mcconnell
moscow mitch so let's let's listen to
that quorum this
coronet let's talk moscow mitch
mcconnell throws a tortoise tantrum
and decides he doesn't want it in the
filibuster
threatens that if the democrats in the
filibuster that
he'll call quorum and it'll be scored
stirred politics
good luck [ __ ] oh goodness that [ __ ]
filibuster is in and
the democrats can pass the john lewis
voting rights act that puts a big [ __ ]
you on their voter suppression plans
i wonder why they don't want to end the
filibuster hmm
what's in this racist archaic procedure
and stop this minority rule
[ __ ] and let the majority do policy
in this country
[ __ ] them so there you go
that's it the john lewis voting rights
act that's what they're scared of
they're terrified of that thing and the
reason why is because
it will prevent them from from
suppressing the vote which is their plan
to hang on to power in the senate
uh they've already got gerrymandering
figured out which if that gets taken
away from them they're really [ __ ]
so their idea their their game here
their game here is to suppress the vote
for these senate races because they
can't gerrymander a senate race
there's no gerrymandering a senate race
the senate race is statewide
they can't change the shape of the state
but what they can do is
change the shape of who votes and when
they vote and how they vote and
how much access they have to voting they
can change that
they know that and that's what their
[ __ ] plan is here
is is is to keep black people from
voting
that's their plan sorry to be so
[ __ ] blunt about it but that's the
truth
if they know they can keep minorities
from voting
and keep young liberal white people from
voting
they can win but i honestly think
after trumpism and what's happened with
the 81 million people voting for biden
i actually think this idea that the
majority of white people are
are still in in their camp after january
6th and i think that's actually what
we're going to see
with some of these primaries that are
going to happen on the republican side
because
there's already movement there already
movement roy blunt's retired
it looks like that [ __ ] scuzz bag
piece of [ __ ] ron johnson's gonna have
to retire
uh that's what he's doing is floating
yeah everyone you know everyone's up in
arms about his
uh his little statements on black lives
matter in antifa if it was black lives
matter and antifa that did january 6 he
would have been terrified
of course he would have been because
he's a racist
and he's a race baiter but what he's
trying to do with those statements and
the reason why he made him is because he
knew they would blow up
he knew that he's trying to fend off any
challenger in the primary
and that's why roy blunt retired out of
missouri because he knows he's gonna get
a challenge from the trump right
and he can't be as trumpy as someone
other trumpy
he knows that he roy blunt knows he
wasn't gonna be as trumpy as eric
greitens or billy long
he knows that that's why he bowed out
before it even started because he's not
even gonna try to do that
he's gonna hang on to his legacy
same way as the rest of them two me and
the rest of them they know they're gonna
get challenges from the trump right
these
knuckleheads these q and on [ __ ]
marjory taylor green bobert types
and some of these [ __ ] are
gonna win primaries and we're gonna have
a roy moore situation in several states
where the [ __ ] the [ __ ] republican
candidate is just so far out there
that even republicans are [ __ ]
grossed out
republican voters are [ __ ] grossed
out jesus christ
i mean that that's where we're headed
here and roy blunt knows it ron johnson
knows it that's why ron johnson's trying
to be trump
he's trying to be trump because he he
doesn't want someone to challenge him
and the thing is is if he can convince
all the challengers
in wisconsin the trumpies these two and
on trump [ __ ]
that want to run in wisconsin that want
that seat
and want to primary him if he can
convince them that he's going to
convince the electorate
that he's he's all in with trump he's
balls deep into the trumpism
then [ __ ] he we won't get a challenge he
won't have a primary challenge
so that's what he's trying to do he's
trying to fend off any challenge here
and wait it out
so we're gonna continue to see ron
johnson be a racist piece of garbage
for the next six months and he ain't
gonna resign either no matter how much
we
hashtag it on twitter he ain't gonna
resign because the whole point of him
the whole point of him saying this [ __ ]
the whole point of him saying this stuff
is to try to fend off a primary
challenger
and keep them at bay so
rather he will or not that's the
question i hope he gets primaried [ __ ]
him
i hope they all get primaried i hope
there's a lot of trumpy trumpy trump
trumps
in these primaries because i really
think that's where we're going to see
how this elections how 2024 could play
out
where trumpism is in this country how
many people they lost after january 6
what does the electorate look like
because i believe after january 6 the
electorate has changed
it has changed that's what i believe
and the reason why i think it has
changed is because of the j
the events of january 6 i believe a lot
of people who voted for trump was like
there's no way that could happen
boom it happens or he's not gonna he's
not gonna try to commit a coup
he tried to commit a coup
and a lot of republicans elected
republicans were complicit in it
and i'm looking at you josh holly ted
cruz ron johnson
mo brooks tommy tuberville
i'm looking at you
so we'll see there's a lot of senate
races
and the trumpies of the trump trumps are
going to be in the primaries that's why
they're bowing out
that's why they're terrified of this
john lewis voting rights act
because their plan was to shore up those
states by keeping
by keeping moderates independents
progressives and liberals
from from access to ballots that was the
whole point
whether it be mail-in whether it be
physical locations
rather it means purging people from the
[ __ ] roles whatever it
whatever they can do to make sure that
those senate races are shored up because
there's one goddamn thing they know
one goddamn thing they know that they
cannot retain power without that senate
they won't they can't they will not and
mitch mcconnell's speech
on the floor from what i read i did not
read the whole thing
but from what i read he sounds a little
terrified that he's not
it's almost like i'm planning on
retiring
i'm bowing out here if they do this
filibuster because if they do this
filibuster we
are [ __ ] and the reason why they're
[ __ ] is because of the john lewis
voting rights act
and that needs to be our number one
issue in this country is get the
filibuster in a situation where we can
pass the john lewis voting rights act
so we can get on with getting this
country in [ __ ] shape again
isn't it funny isn't it funny how every
time
a democrat takes over after republican
they have to fix the [ __ ]
country they have to fix the economy
because they [ __ ] smashed it up with
a hammer
isn't it funny huh i wonder if that's
just a [ __ ] coincidence
it's not it's not a [ __ ] coincidence
it's not a [ __ ] coincidence
speaking of the economy and this country
we still have the coronavirus going on
the pandemic everyone acts as a lot of
people are acting like it's over
like oh we got the we got that we got
the vaccination it's there
people are getting it i'm not getting it
but people are getting it so it's over
we don't have to wear a mask anymore we
can do whatever the
[ __ ] we want spring break
you dumb [ __ ]
you understand that if you go do what
you want to do
and you [ __ ] this up you're just going
to prolong this process for
a couple months you're just going to
prolong this [ __ ] so if you don't
like the [ __ ]
what are you doing
be patient stop [ __ ] around
put your [ __ ] mask on don't be
crowding up in groups
and [ __ ] off like that
just be patient you got two or three
more months until we get to some kind of
hurt immunity that they can prove we
have hurt immunity
and and god if you want to gather up in
groups with your friends make sure all
your friends get vaccinated
encourage them to get vaccinated the cdc
has already said
yes if you need if you want to have a
small gatherings indoors with people who
are vaccinated that is fine
so god damn there's a way to do this and
it's not to go down and have spring
break and cough on each other
and give each other coronavirus and then
fly back to all [ __ ] parts of the
[ __ ] country and spread it around in
these communities
god damn it just when we're about to
reach a [ __ ] point where we can say
hey
the lights here at the end of the tunnel
you [ __ ] pump the brakes
because you can't get your [ __ ] head
on right
put a [ __ ] mask on you [ __ ] it's not
that big of a deal put it over your face
god and get the vaccine we're only
asking we're only asking you a couple
more things
for like 90 days 60 to 90 days
now granted we're we're probably going
to have to wear these masks long after
90 days in certain situations
when when we find out that it's it's
it's in a community or it's spreading
around the community
or it's spreading around a school or a
workplace you're probably gonna have to
put on [ __ ] masks
for the next two three years in certain
situations
as long as you're doing the right things
as long as you're
listening to what the health officials
are telling you hey we found it
it's circulating around people you might
want to put a mask on when you go out
[ __ ] we can't even we can't even get get
these people to not crowd up in big
crowds on a beach
and spread it to each other jesus christ
in a couple more months it's very likely
that everything will be open in the
first place
and it'll be a hell of a lot safer it'll
be summer you can go to the beach and
have your parties then
get vaccinated then go party with
everyone who's vaccinated
[ __ ] me just entitled [ __ ] in
this country
entitled [ __ ] cannot wait two
[ __ ] months to do something
jesus
but you know that's my high horse
that's my high horse and again no one's
preventing you from going and doing
things
i mean at this point a lot of in a lot
of these states all this shit's open
anyways
just put on your [ __ ] mask and social
distance where you can wash your hands
do the [ __ ] you've been doing the last
year
do that stuff to keep this down don't be
traveling all the way across the country
to lick each other's faces and [ __ ]
come on coughing each other's drinks
come on a couple more months
[ __ ]
get your [ __ ] right it's not that
difficult
now i appreciate you joining us today
we're
we're we're running we're pretty good on
time here i do want to talk about a
couple things here
uh while i have you while i have your
ears
is that i got a couple things you notice
i got the the gray hat on today the
[ __ ] hat
um so we got those to support our
podcast if you want to support our
podcast that would be great
i would really appreciate that you can
go to thetonymichaels.com
you can click on the hat link and it'll
take you to uh
to get a hat they're the flex fit hats
that i wear
and they get [ __ ] up embroidered on it
and it has the tony michaels on the back
you can see pictures over there there's
black and there's there's gray
there's black and there's gray and so i
would appreciate that the other thing is
we have a merch store
uh i got these in [ __ ] stickers you
guys can get a [ __ ] sticker now
[ __ ] up so you can put that
you know you stick it on your laptop
stick it anywhere you want stick it on
your wall stick it in your ass if you
want to i don't
but no that's that's uh so if you guys
want to support me that way
support the podcast that would be
fantastic we appreciate any support we
love the followers
um and you guys can catch me on tick
tock of course
go follow me over there you can follow
me on the the twitter machine
i know we're we've been streaming on
youtube so subscribe there
and if you aren't subscribed yet what
the hell is wrong with you go ahead and
subscribe
to the youtube channel so you get not
only not only will you get the podcast
notifications
but you'll also get the tick tock videos
because i post my tick tock videos on
youtube
because youtube has this new thing
called shorts
and uh it's their answer to tick tock
you know they're scared tic tocs gonna
take their
their street cred away so they're
starting a thing called shorts where
they have short uh
60 second videos kind of like tick tock
i'm sure it's
going to move more in that direction you
know us
americans we can't keep our attention
longer than 15 30 seconds anyways
i submerged the last few days and post
some videos on tick tock and i do edit
them
i really appreciate you guys doing that
and i'll and i'll continue as you guys
post videos i'll continue to do it
when you post your merch i really do
appreciate all your support
it really does help out to keep doing
the podcast
because we do it does cost a little bit
of money with the subscription fees and
the streaming software and all that kind
of stuff so uh know that all that does
go to the podcast
and i really do appreciate that we want
to get a few more pieces of equipment i
want to get their lights a better
microphone
so all that will go towards that um and
and we've been shooting the last few
days so i'm thinking i need to upgrade
my uh
my computer or something and i know sure
if it's the internet or what but
we're gonna get that figured out soon uh
i think it was just glitching
but you know that happens it happens
when you go live on
on the internet and i like doing it live
the reason why i like doing it live is
because you know it's live
[ __ ] happens things go i just sit here
and talk we don't have to edit it we
don't have to worry about editing it it
just does it itself whatever the [ __ ] it
is that's what it is
and you get you get in trouble with live
because of glitches or technical
difficulties but you know we haven't had
too bad last week there were some
glitches
on the show this week not so much we had
a few there but
but it's going good it's going good so
so join us next week
uh we'll be doing the show the same time
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern
here on youtube we're gonna stream it on
twitter just like we've been doing
i think this is the fourth the third or
fourth time we've actually streamed on
twitter
which a lot of people like to watch over
there which is kind of cool because i
got i got people on twitter
got people on tick tock some are on both
and then i have my youtube subscribers
so i try to try to get you guys that
stuff all the time uh and i do lives
on tick tock right now and actually uh
yesterday i got banned from my lives on
tick tock i got it back i appealed and i
got it back
but uh some some i'm sure some trumper
uh uh reported me
you know because they're [ __ ]
snowflakes you know they
they complain about us being snowflakes
for
for months and months and months but
they can't handle one bad word about
about their orange
deity so if i get to talking about you
know
how [ __ ] uh uh trump is
then we get we get the we get the hammer
over there
so i got banned but i got it i got my
eyes back so i go live on on tick tock
i'm gonna try to go live on
on twitter uh maybe sometimes some
people just keep saying instagram but
i don't know if we're gonna do that but
all right guys thanks for watching today
i appreciate you hanging out with us
and we'll see you next time on tony
michaels the tony michaels podcast
[ __ ] em you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them